il ya de fortes chances que vous
finissiez dans un ravin on a retrouvé
des amis italiens qui on a retrouvé mort
en bas d'une falaise
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup d'événements très curieux
il ya des gens qui ont des fins et
brutale quoi pour bodoï vous raconter
l'histoire d'un repenti de la fraude à
grande échelle dans les paradis fiscaux
il est devenu espion pour la dgse
pourtant maxime renahy a grandi très
loin des banques offshore et des
services de renseignement
je suis né à grande synthe dans le
nord-pas-de-calais ont fait travailler à
l'usiné dont conviction simplement
j'ai fait une formation pour dent
dans l'hôtellerie de luxe
m
ensuite je suis parti à l'étranger en
grande bretagne pour apprendre l'anglais
et de fil en aiguille j'ai rencontré une
personne une minable moquette qui m'a
dit à un moment donné
est ce que tu veux aller travailler à
jarzé je suis arrivé en février
2007 à jarzé
je suis ça m'intéressait parce que
c'était pour moi paradis fiscal c'était
synonyme de mystère le sucre est la
lutte contre les paradis fiscaux
c'est payé à la fiscalité très souple a
accusé de favoriser l'évasion de
capitaux
on pense souvent à eux désignent des
caraïbes mais plusieurs de ces paradis
sont à moins d'une heure d'avion de
paris la petite île anglo normande de
jersey plus de 600 milliards d'euros de
capitaux étrangers ils transiteraient
sans aucune transparence
je connais un peu la géographie lille
c'est petit c'est il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent il ya les villas
incroyable les types qui arrivent en jet
on hélicoptères ont les bateaux fin mai
mais c'est en même temps petit c'est une
micro société qui brasse énormément
d'argent
c'est le paradis fiscal en tout 500 da
j'ai une interview dans le plus grand
cabinet d'avocats deal qui s'appelait à
l'époque ou mourants
on dit tout de suite écoute on a besoin
d'une personne qu'ils soient
francophones on va te former
ne t'inquiète pas si tu n'as aucune
formation dans la finance c'est très
particulier la finance offshore
[Musique]
je suis rentré totalement dans un
nouveau monde dont je connaissais
absolument rien du tout faire
c'est plutôt des gens des trentenaires
qui sont célibataires jeunes sorbonne
enfants qui gagne
pas mal d'argent c'est des mecs qui
bossent toute la semaine s'est dévoué
aux essais mécaniques pas créatif et c&a
par picoler prendre un peu de cas mais
puis d epuis baiser c'est l'alcool la
drogue et les sexes ce cabinet d'avocats
il a pour fonctions d'ouvrir des
sociétés pour le compte de clients qui
sont par exemple en france en allemagne
donc si les incorpore à jersey et
ensuite ils les administre
[Musique]
c'est une société qui basé à jersey
uniquement pour administrer les biens de
ces gens qui sont extrêmement riches
pourront pas payer d'impôts si on résume
au maximum c'est ça c'est à dire une
présence fictive en fait dans les
paradis fiscaux pour ne pas avoir payé
d'impôts tout est illégal en fait c'est
ça le fond du problème
sauf que c'est tellement complexe tous
ces montages que les gens riches et les
médias meanstream nous disent oui mais
c'est en zone grise
vous avez pas compris on va vous
expliquer je peux vous dire quand vous
êtes du côté de l'autre côté vous voyez
clairement que ces fraudes en permanence
d'ailleurs au mieux c'est plus de
l'évasion fiscale et au pire c'était des
investissements interdit c'est du
blanchiment d'argent
[Musique]
le contexte était très intrigant pour
moi c'était à paris on a marché très
vite il m'a fait marché extrêmement vite
jacques fait regarder derrière lui on il
m'a fait passer dans des endroits dans
des passages parisiens on arrive ensuite
dans un café une brasserie et là il a
sorti son carnet puis mme dumont il m'a
demandé mon qu'est-ce que vous avez pour
nous je savais qu'avec les dossiers que
j'avais pris avec moi j'allais veiller
son attention donc tout de suite ils
devenus beaucoup plus calme et moins
stressé moins tendue il a pris en note
il a passé un petit coup de fil
il m'a dit on va vérifier tout ça on va
revenir
vous et c'est ce qui s'est passé m'a dit
vous savez si jamais vous parlez que ça
se passe mal pour te fera plus jamais de
travail dans le monde de la finance de
l'assurance et c'était un jeune homme
est un peu de souci je comprends
parfaitement fait des enjeux
et c'est faire une petite formation
pendant deux jours j'ai dû faire mon
itinéraire de sécurité que j'avais créé
avec le formateur pour rejoindre de
façon sécurisé aux fichiers traitants
il faut faire croire aux adversaires
qu'il ya un but assez chine et heitinga
trouvez les rues les angles pour
s'échapper à toute vitesse en quand on
puisse vous retrouver pour détecter des
gens qui vous suivent et le formateur
était redoutable que je veux dire il ya
un moment donné il m'a demandé que je le
suive dans un exercice il m'a sommé en
quelques minutes
le but évidemment c'est de ne pas être
suivis faut absolument pas remonter
jusqu'à la dgse quoi
[Musique]
pour faire passer leur demande les
services secrets français envoient
maxime renahy ce qu'ils appellent des
listes de courses et c'est un ensemble
de demande extrêmement pointus technique
la part des services parce que tu peux
trouver des profils à jersey confisqué
recruter qui est derrière cette boîte
russe qui est derrière cette boîte
américaine est ce que tu peux infiltrés
par exemple au luxembourg tel réseau ou
telle raison
c'était très très très large à
je travaille par exemple amour en a à z
je pouvais vous voyez des choses c'est
ce que je faisais sur place mais aussi
j'avais pour mission de trouver les étés
placés les serveurs quel type de serveur
qui s'en occupe et c est de se charger
de prendre des informations à distance
depuis la france
si vous voulez avoir des informations il
faut aller soit jersey soit acquis les
serveurs de jason
à vous de ce fichier traitant aller sur
la boîte mail de intel dans le folder
douala tel endroit vous allez trouver
tel dossier
et c est avec les remontées d'argent
allemand suite je vous les expliquer
[Musique]
c'était dangereux parce que les anglo
saxons sont moins compréhensif que les
français si vous leur piquer des infos
il ya de fortes chances
vous finissiez il ya beaucoup
d'événements très curieux
il ya des gens qui s'ils ont des fins et
brutale quoi on a retrouvé mes amis
italiens qu'ils étaient gestionnaires
qui était à 30 centimètres de moi qui
travaille et qui on a retrouvé mort en
bas d'une falaise pour moi c'est
extrêmement dur c'était violent quoi je
dis on le voit vendredi
je passe bien je passais mon temps à
rigoler avec free et lundi on nous
annonce qui on l'a retrouvée en bas
d'une falaise pas du tout qu'il soit
suicidé
[Musique]
quand j'ai commencé à me rendre compte
qu'à chaque fois quand j'avais dénoncé
des abus de biens sociaux ou d'autre
chose et que ça partait à la trappe
vous avez forcément une frustration qui
commence à s'installer
il ya eu le sentiment à mon avis
justifiée que tout le travail qu'ils
faisaient toutes les infos qu'il a menée
ces officiers traitants ou les agents de
ne traitez pas grand chose
à
jetons
ce que j'espère c'est qu'un jour peut
être
puis les services puissent infiltré des
groupes de financiers pour ensuite
ramener des dizaines de milliards des
centaines de milliards sur la france et
les mettre en prison 10 15 24 ans en
prison parce que quelque part c'est pas
uniquement un délit c'est un crime